y este viernes las elecciones de fútbol
femenino de Francia y Colombia
disputarán un partido amistoso como
parte de la preparación para lo que será
su participación en la copa del mundo
que se celebrará en Australia y en Nueva
Zelanda para la selección francesa el
encuentro cobra mayor relevancia pues
era el primer partido con el banquillo
tras la salida de la seleccionadora
colindiak Master el siguiente reporte de
Natalia Ruiz giraldo
la selección Colombia femenina realizó
su último entrenamiento antes del
amistoso en el que se enfrentará a la
selección francesa aquí en selección
colombiana que está en plena gira
Europea de Cara a su preparación antes
de este mundial de fútbol que tendrá
lugar en el verano entre Australia y
Nueva Zelanda tuvimos la oportunidad
consejo y Ferreira de hablar con Néstor
abadía el director técnico de Colombia y
nos dijo que era Cuál era la importancia
de este partido para la selección para
nosotros es un reto llamativo es un reto
bueno saber que tenemos este partido con
Francia y más acá en su país ese algo
que es estimulante por lo que es Francia
pero más importante para nosotros es lo
que tenemos y sabemos que debemos hacer
para las francesas también es un partido
importante sobre todo porque será el
primero bajo la batuta de ajonar Después
de varias semanas de crisis y de cambio
por supuesto de entrenador quien dijo en
conferencia de que está seguro de estar
construyendo algo importante pero que su
nivel de exigencia para las jugadoras va
a ser bastante elevado Además de eso
también está la expectativa de lo
público pues ya toda la boletería para
este partido del viernes se agotó Así
que veremos Diez mil novecientas almas
en las graderías de este